these are bleak times for manchester
united the team that once set the
benchmark for premier league greatness
now engulfed in gloom
for the first time in 30 years a
season's begun with two defeats
the blame game is very much focused up
in the stands on the owners in a stadium
where the glazers are far from welcome
protests greeted their takeover in 2005
and the fan anger persists over the debt
personal profiteering and under
investment in the team
rage that forced last year's visit of
liverpool to be called off before
kickoff
there's no public descent against the
glaciers from inside old trafford former
directors will speak out
my message to the glazer family is
you've run out of road
please with honor with dignity with
professionalism just quietly push the
exit door now your time's finished it's
over
and the man to sell this football club
to
is british man sir jim ratcliffe sir jim
radcliffe has now gone public with his
dreams of buying into the club he
supported long before investments in
ineos turned him into one of britain's
richest men the chemicals company saying
in a statement if something like this
was possible we would be interested in
talking with a view to long-term
ownership
this is not about the money that has
been spent or not spent jim is looking
at what can be done now and knowing how
important the club is to the city it
feels like the time is right for a reset
regardless of the current struggles on
the pitch manchester united remained one
of the most desirable sports teams to
own in the world there is no indication
from the glazers though that they are
willing to sell up completely yet and
even sir jim ratcliffe has only said he
is exploring a potential deal and
there's no sign of any official bid yet
to be tabled with the owners
it is the debt that stands around 500
million pounds so enraging supporters
and the more than 1 billion pounds spent
in interest payments and fees across 17
years
the most important people in football to
support is they're the people
who love the club who care about the
club who are passionate about the club
and uh they should they should be right
in this the heart of the club they
should be embedded to the club and
whoever takes over
really has to take that on border i
think what's unclear is how much united
would cost far more than the two and a
half billion pounds chelsea were sold
for this year but investment is needed
in the stadium infrastructure and in the
struggling squad
what about money for new players sir are
you able to invest we've always spent
the money necessarily by new players
a rarity for fans in a sky news
interview this year to hear from one of
the glazers
owners who it's understood are open to
minority investment but seem no close to
giving fans the transfer long desired a
change at the top rob harris sky news
old trafford